un an après le lancement des travaux du
vélodrome dirigeants et membres de
l'équipe de france rendez visite ce
mardi à leur futur quartier
d'entraînement à saint quentin en
yvelines
comment dieu mais je pars que jamais
vrai boulodrome dans la région qu il y
en aura d'autres imputent ya quelques
mois c'était celui de robert et le
chantier dans les temps les tribunes qui
entoureront la piste avec une capacité
de 5000 places sont déjà construites au
delà du vélodrome c'est un vrai
clairefontaine du vélo qui va poser ses
braqué à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un vrai centre national du
cyclisme au delà même de d'être un
vélodrome avec le siège de la fédération
ici on sait vivre à vélo ça va respirer
vélo et les administratives les
personnels vont pouvoir côtoyer les
sportifs ayora durable des vététistes
les dames
et les pilotes de bmx les pistes à la
piste du vélodrome sera unique de par la
qualité de son bois sélectionnés en
sibérie mais aussi par son architecture
qui favorisera les performances des
pistards 250 mètres de long sur 8 mètres
de large
des dimensions pensée pour faire tomber
les records l'ouverture du vélodrome est
prévue pour décembre 2013 avec de
possibles au championnat de france dès
mais en attendant la visite s'est
achevée par la soirée des champions
l'occasion de rendre hommage aux
médaillés olympiques mais aussi aux
jeunes espoirs qui connaît